hi it's Larry herb Xbox Live's Major
Nelson here with Richard Irving from the
Xbox engineering team back with us
Richard thanks for joining us again
always great to be here thank you we've
got some great stuff coming for Xbox one
new update around the corner what can
fans expect in June well this is a
really really big update we've added
support for external storage being able
to share your real name with people on
your friends list a bunch of important
improvements to smart glass and as we've
already announced this is the system
update that enables you to access
popular apps like Netflix and Hulu and
machinima without requiring you to have
an Xbox Live Gold membership great stuff
now let's go right back to the top I
want to talk about external storage a
lot of a lot of fans have been waiting
for that tell us how it's gonna work
well the basic compatibility requirement
is you need a USB 3.0 compatible Drive
with 256 gigabytes or more available on
it awesome and then and then tell me a
little bit more about how that works
well so you plug it into the console
will recognize that you've attached a
compatible device ask if you want to
format it will format the format the
device and from that point forward it
now becomes the default storage device
for all the content that you download so
the next game that you download will go
to the USB Attached drive instead of the
internal hard drive but when you run out
of space will automatically spill over
into the Xbox one hard drive ok you can
go into your collection and take all the
stuff that you've already downloaded to
your Xbox one hard drive move it over to
your external drive and then you have
everything in one nice neat little
package if you want to bring it over
your friends house and play on their
Xbox one now one of the neat features I
saw is you can actually use multiple
drives is that right that's right you
can use a maximum of two drives
simultaneously so bringing the total of
the three storage devices including the
internal hard drive that is awesome news
tell us about real names that sounds
very interesting well real names is
something that's that's important to us
and many people have asked for you know
gamer tags are a fantastic thing to have
when you're in a multiplayer game but
when you're out browsing your friends
list when you have you know a thousand
people that on
friends list that you were following I
can at times be a little confusing who's
who so the first time you launch the
friends app after the June update will
ask if you want to enable real name
sharing if you say you don't then
everyone will always know you by your
gamertag so in my case major Nelson
that's right okay if you say that you do
we will then ask you for which of your
friends do you want to enable real names
for and you can be you can simply select
all of your friends if you want or you
can select them individually one by one
if that's your choice if you want to
have a little more control over who's
seeing your real name so people can see
my real name Larry herb either everybody
a few people or nobody in it again my
choice that's right and you can be very
very specific about who on your friends
list can see your real name so there's
another really cool feature of real
names where you can enable a further
discovery through friends of friends by
enabling your real name to be shared
through friends of friends how does this
work with followers well so your
followers will always know you by
gamertag unless you also add them as a
friend oh that makes sense
all right so let's talk about smart
glass some great new features coming
give us some of the highlights well
there's actually a bunch of great new
features in smart glass there's a set of
features that deepen your connection
with your social network on Xbox Live
all right when you start the smart glass
app you'll notice that the Activity Feed
is now on the home screen you can see
what your friends are up to quickly at a
glance on your phone when you're away
from the console so it's just like the
Activity Feed console more or less
that's right it will take you straight
to achievement comparison if you've seen
achievements been unlocked but the other
cool thing is broadcast notifications
for your friends that are broadcasting
on Twitch you'll now get the
notification on your smart glass device
and if you act on that notification
you'll be taken straight to the twitch
experience wherever you are to see what
your friend is up to in that game and of
course you don't obviously watch it
that's right
that's awesome awesome what else do we
have so there's another set of features
that broaden its use as a companion to
your console so something is as simple
but as requested as pin reordering so
you can discreetly reorder the pins on
your console using smart glass so the
favorite things I have on my on my
console over on the left hand side
you can now go into smart clash and be
able to just dynamically rearrange them
exactly the way you want by color
alphabetically any way I want that's
exactly right
okay so rich earthers additional
enhancements coming to smart class
regarding the guide right that's right
so as we've already announced the one
guy this it cut is coming to smart glass
so you'll be able to see TV listings on
your smart glass device but we're also
launching a universal remote control
feature as part of smart glass so that
you can control your TV experience and
all the other AV components that you
have in your system using your smart
glass device so I'll be able to control
my TV volume or my AV volume turn it up
and turn it down mute it and do whatever
I want to change channels and that's
absolutely right it's a really cool
feature Richard you have any other
features you'd like to mention
yeah actually in response to customer
feedback we are introducing the much
requested Auto sign-in feature with this
release now what does that mean
what that means is you'll be able to
configure one of the accounts on your
console to automatically sign in every
time you power up or come out of
connected standby awesome Richard Irving
from the Xbox engineering team thanks
for the updates and thanks for your time
today thanks for having me